okay thank you that's an interesting
segue into what I'm going to talk about
this is not a talk on securities a talk
on trustfulness
and that encompasses safety reliability
interoperability anything you want
predictable real-time behavior
autonomous systems aircraft and anything
else is in scope so the weirdness about
this whole thing is that I've been doing
this well my first job was 1953 working
for the Navy as a programmer and along
about 65 I started on multix I was at
Bell Labs in the entire 60s and in the
70s we did a system for NSA that some of
you guys know about the proof of a
secure operating system with formally
specified hardware and in 76 I was asked
to create and what what I did when I
started doing there was pick horror
stories that had happened and make sure
that every issue of that thing since
July of 76 had some horror stories in it
oddly enough I have contributed to every
issue of every regular issue since in
one way or another and so this is the
risk stuff started in in 76 when I del
cobre came to me and said we need a
visibility of the ACM and so I'm wearing
like a cm shirt here to be visible and
so she said why don't you create some
sort of an online representation which
which I did and that is still going
today some of you are subscribers to it
the students should be reading it
regularly because it's full of wonderful
things about what goes wrong recently
we've had stuff like
the 737 max and all of the problems
there the experience that one comes to
very quickly is that there are no single
causes for a failure that one was one
where it was very clear that boeing was
moving on testing and oversimplifying
what they had to do the FAA was
incapable of monitoring them the company
moved to Chicago from United or fully
moved to Chicago actually and the the
ethic in this country or the ethos maybe
of paying off your stockholders before
you worried about safety and reliability
and all these other trustworthy issues
that I've been mentioning is such that
where we're getting ourselves into a
real bind
so what I thought I'd do today was was
get through some of the history and I
know you guys have a lot of horror
stories that you would be happy to offer
so this is not a talk that I expect to
give as as a normal hour and a half talk
hour okay well that's true yeah
thank you so I'd love to to get you guys
involved now the hope was that there
would be more students here sitting with
us live that's not working out but I've
got another shot shot at you in three
weeks when I'm going to have to be
talking about the hard work that we've
been building for the past nine years
and some of the recent developments of
bringing this into the real world
and I'm also going to talk about the
thunderclap paper which is a wonderful
USBC stick which completely takes over
every system that you put it in and it's
a symptomatic problem of a fundamental
flaw and essentially every system that
that is worrying about direct memory
access from embedded devices and and
external i/o so what I would like to do
today is simply to walk through some of
the horror stories that we have it goes
way back and I have I basically multiple
persona one is the risks forum stuff
which as you hear is ongoing for a long
time the other is the idea build trying
to build trustworthy systems which some
of you have been heavily involved in for
the nears so that's next talk in three
weeks
today let's just talk about what are the
things that go wrong then what can we do
about them so I my book which you don't
need to go out and buy and it's
available for one penny on Amazon it
says a used copy it's better if you get
third of the fourth printing because
there are fewer typos and correct type
of are on my website to correct them if
you do happen to stumble onto it
first edition first printing I should
say I look at the the safety problems as
something that is over Archie if you
don't have secure systems you don't have
safety if you don't have reliable
systems you don't have safety if you
don't have reliable systems you don't
have security you don't have security
you don't have safety so the problem is
that everything is interrelated in some
way and I know you have worried about
some of these hierarchical airings where
you depend only on lower layers you
never depend on something that is less
trustworthy if you can help it and
that's sort of it they can buy the thing
that some of you know about so what do
we do that if we're trying to build
something yeah yes true well the
hardware this is untrustworthy given
given this talk I mean he came in three
weeks all of the hardware is untrusted
yeah and and then you have fictions like
SEO for which is a secure microkernel
which has been proved correct with
respect to all of the assumptions
they've made but it has to trust that
the hardware is correct and I just
addressed all of the application code so
the idea of building something on sand
is not a happy one
I'll mentioned in three weeks that
Microsoft has come to us and said that
70% of their security problems are
little memory management problems and
that our hardware in fact takes care of
all of those 70% of their flaws that's
an interesting thought if true and we're
still in the process of trying to
determine that but that's for three
weeks from now for today I'm getting a
little hoarse let me grab a cough drop
there today I think I would like to
focus on some of the horror stories that
you guys might have mine go way way back
into passwords in the CCSS the story of
the day in which the fortune cookie
today came out as the entire unencrypted
password file
because the guy who had built the editor
for CCSS had assumed that there would
never be two people in the same process
or the same directory working at the
same time so he had one fixed name
temporary file and he exchanged the
temporary file with it with the working
file so beautifully the the password
file and the fortune cookie file got
crossed over you know this is a simple
problem and you think gee we've got to
be able to not be that stupid
well shortsightedness is the I think I
use this Einstein quote a lot that
everything should be made as simple as
possible but no simpler and it's there's
no simpler that sometimes gets to you I
had a Exam Question I made in 1980 1956
I think when I was ta ta the
undergraduate computer course and it
required that four or five four five
line program to invert the order of the
bits in a string and one of the students
managed to make three programming errors
in the same five line program he had an
off by one in the loop he had a couple
of other errors and I thought gee that's
that's interesting what what can we do
with a 5-line program
well a TMT on Martin Luther King Day in
1990 you were around and some of you
were not around then had a very simple
fix to they're switching their network
switch stuff and he made it for a 5-line
program that changed the routing
algorithm after a system had crashed
and they didn't test it because they
figured it's only five lines they called
her before or whatever it was and so
what happens I think some of you may
remember the day when you could not get
a long-distance call across the country
and what happened was very simple that
when I switched crashed it rebooted
itself and originally sent a message to
the other neighbors saying that we are
now live again they said we don't need
to do that we just need to start sending
traffic and they started sending traffic
and it crashed all of their neighbors
which then rebooted and started sending
traffic to all of their neighbors which
crashed all of their neighbors and this
went on for half a day some of you heard
the story that three days later I got a
phone call from to New York Bronx
science kids acid frickin fiber-optic
and they say did you hear anything I
said what do you mean did I hear
anything
well we went on the switch that crashed
and we're afraid that AT&T is gonna
blame us for having brought down the
entire I said don't worry two things one
is that they've now demonstrated that
this was a bug in their software
secondly they're claiming that there was
never a hacker on any of the switches or
switch controllers this is impossible it
couldn't happen so how can they come out
of the closet to say oh yes we're gonna
blame these two high school kids okay so
here's a simple example of a propagating
error we've had I go back to 1965 or
November I think it was I'm standing on
the top floor of project Mac 545
Technology Square and standing from him
in the computer room with Bob Dailey and
all of a sudden
Wow and we have the Northeast blackout
okay so yeah folks and the power
industry said well we're gonna fix that
we're going to change the algorithm so
that can't happen again
and in my risks archive I have probably
six or eight nine total blackouts of
either our entire West Coast the entire
West Coast plus Baja California and and
Vancouver
another East Coast one and you say well
gee why can't people build algorithms
that are sound that anticipate all of
the things that can go wrong and that's
that's a lovely question and the answer
is because nobody's paying attention to
all of these things that have gone wrong
in the past they assume oh we can fix
that with a little patch I think I
mentioned to you once that I am using a
very old mailer Columbia hmmm which of
course went completely to pieces on y2k
and so somebody generated a patch which
failed on January 1st 2001 so there was
another patch for that which failed on
alright so how do we think in the large
about things that go wrong how do we
anticipate all the horrible things that
can go wrong so the reason I'm here is
to suggest that in this risks forum that
I've been running for god knows how long
and in its precursor in the software
engineering notes that there had been
one horrible story after another and in
relationship to what you said in the
beginning we've been there before
everything that was in the risks for him
in my book in 1995 it's still happening
today in one way or another so the
bottom line for this talk is
particularly for the students to say
think about what can go wrong and try to
design things that won't fall flat on
their faces when when something does go
wrong okay so with that much as
background I can go on for hours and
hours and hours on on specific cases but
I wanted to get into some discussion
with you guys about not only how can we
have event to prevent this but how can
we improve the education in such a way
that people who are teaching about
computer systems and software and
hardware and so on are going to find
that the students are becoming more
aware of whatever certainly you talked
about there have been lots of problems
in software the very first well it
didn't lead admission but but they had
to delay the launch by two days because
the guys who designed this damn thing
never told the operational guys that
there was a one in 64 probability of
failure when they tried to reboot
because the four primary computers could
not link up with
back up computer and all I had to do was
rebooted and it would have worked but it
took them two days to figure that out
because the the designers and the
implementers had never told the
operational guys that there was this
possibility it's a trivial thing to do
andum random testing probability of 63
out of 64 that it's going to work so
testing doesn't prove very much in that
case they did test it you said the word
software yeah now you remember the the
Challenger and the o-rings okay so very
nice articles that was Apollo yeah and
one of my buddies my grad school buddies
was the guy who designed the Apollo
guidance computer Draper and we were
having a competition with him in terms
of who was gonna build the most reliable
system ours was the software implemented
fault-tolerant thing that did 10 to the
minus 10 probability of failure probably
if the hardware was 10 to the minus 5 we
fell we got five orders of magnitude but
it was seven processor seven buses seven
power supplies and you could pull out a
board and it self-diagnosed itself
reconfigured and now Hopkins was
designing this very tightly constrained
Apollo guidance computer yeah if you
look at the shuttle software
I can't I once tried to calculate how
many lines of debug code
they got per person per
today the answer was three one okay
it may well my very rough calculation
really no but again you mentioned the
word software you've forgotten the
hardware the people the attackers the
whole mess and I have two cases in my
history of my personal history the first
one was the air traffic controller
remediation where IBM was writing a
proposal s arrives is helping with the
graphics for for the controllers what
needed to be on the screen and lo and
behold I walk in there you've heard you
may have heard this story I say you show
me the architecture for your on route
traffic control remediation with
overlapping sectors and communications
among all of the different sectors as
the plane flies us and the guy says what
do you mean I reject you we're gonna use
a mainframe okay so for four billion
dollars later and many many years they
cancelled the entire project few years
later I'm at the the IRS as the
commissioners Advisory Group member as a
privacy advocate and I walk in there and
I say show me the architecture for your
modernization program and the guy who
was in charge of all this is what do you
mean architecture we're going to use the
mainframe all of our programmers our
mainframe
that's all they know and the system
engineers were guys who didn't
understand developing systems another
four billion dollars down the tubes so
you talk about software but it's in
three weeks I'm going to talk about
thunderclap which is this devastating
hardware attack and you gotta think big
when you in the shuttle but yes yeah but
just the ones that I've documented are
are all over the map in terms of what
happened now when when Al Hopkins
designed that Apollo guidance computer
the NASA guy said we can't ever let the
astronauts touch the hardware so we're
going to embed it three levels deep
under all kinds of stuff so they can
never get at it there was a shuttle
flight later where they had to actually
had to replace the board and they
figured out well maybe we better not put
the hardware embedded so deeply that
they can't touch it that's the old story
about the the
the dog so at any rate yeah I think most
people think software
I think hardware software people
networks squirrels SSRI has had seven
squirrel sides the first five I think
were where the squirrel arced himself a
arced himself over the junction between
PG&E and and that's right
so we put in a cogeneration plant and
that had been up for a few weeks and the
squirrel arcs himself across the
cogeneration plant junction with with
the GV fries SR I might one of my
computer is completely completely fried
in the process so the problems that we
have to deal with are tremendously
varied hardware software people hackers
and god knows what
squirrels power power outages and this
is this is well heady so how do we we're
gonna worry it in three weeks about how
do we design something that is really
secure reliable and trustworthy but for
today the idea is what can we do for the
youth of America and all of the farm
students who are going to go off and
build stuff elsewhere to understand that
these risks are there and they've been
there for as long as I can remember and
I'm 87 I go way back in the way that my
own wayback machine and the comment I
made earlier is that we keep making the
same mistakes over and over
or again in different guises perhaps but
they're still basically the same buffer
overflows yeah well yes that's an
interesting question for those of you
out there who were former MIT people a
mighty used to teach salt sir and
Schroeder and later cashiers they used
to teach a lot of things about the
principles of security and operating
systems
not much in hardware even though multics
was very innovative in terms of its
hardware my comment education goes back
to the MIT days where the cryptographers
do not have to take a systems course and
so I keep getting cryptographers coming
to me and saying look I've got this
absolutely perfect 100% guaranteed
cryptographic algorithm and nobody can
break and it's like one of these movies
where the guy pulls out a gun and shoots
that the the martial arts guy if our
systems are so fundamentally broken in
hardware and in software and in
operational procedures and preventive
maintenance and God knows what else we
need a fundamental change in education
and there's an article that I just
published in the C ACM this month one of
the other things that I'd mentioned
which I didn't mention this is the
inside risk series in which started
90 I think this is how might we increase
the system trustworthiness that's in the
current issue of the CSD ruffcut it what
might we do to make things better but
it's by no means an answer so getting
back to your question not in education
the reason I'm here where I mentioned to
Dennis Allison that this might be one of
the multiple topics I'd be happy to talk
about was simply that over the years
I've come to Stanford I taught at
Stanford in 64
I've come here and gone through this
kind of reasoning so this is not a new
concept for me this is something I've
been banging on for forever so what do
we do in education to make students
aware that it's more than this
programming language that they've
learned and now they think they are
software engineers or what is more is it
that they can understand that the
hardware is flawed
and if the hardware is going to fail
then you can't trust the operating
system and the applications so very
simple comment the question is how do
you actually get to the point where our
students today begin to understand of it
some of you have been there before and
you've been through all of us many times
and you didn't build systems it didn't
work and you learned presumably learned
lessons from it somebody asked me how I
learned so much about security I said by
doing stuff wrong
I remember Andy Kinslow in 60s against
against low in 67 in 67 he was asked how
he could build an IBM system that was
more robust and he said if only then let
me do it one over I get it right the
second time
maybe yeah and Fred Fred Brooks always
said build one and to throw it away so
you can learn something from it but the
problem is that we don't learn from our
mistakes
some of us do you do I do but this is
not something that is taught what do we
know about teaching how to build large
systems well I grew up in the multics
era for five years I was commuting to
MIT every other week from Bell Labs and
I learned about building software
Corbett oh who just died fact I'm going
to his memorial service a couple of
weeks was somebody who was a stickler
for detail and we had a system where
nobody write writes the line of code
until there was a Pacific nation talking
about all of the inputs to the module
and all of the outputs and what was the
state space long before there was this
formal methodology of regulating that
this was 65 and 65 we solved the buffer
overflow problem in 65
we solved the y2k problem in Baltics
okay so why there's a question for you
guys why didn't that a buffer and
anybody else know never said it did no
but I'm just saying that it solved
something not oh there's other system
solve a different perhaps overlap
yeah but if 10 years ago 70% of all
problems were buffer overflows then
you'd think somebody would say hey why
don't we go back in history and figure
out how that was done in multis
translates to you get thrown the 370 in
what company wouldn't have made that
choice even if it was somewhat less
reliable
depends who's paying for it but if you
if you can get away with making garbage
and selling it then you've got a
business model that's a good question
can you can you hire people who know how
to build good software there are there
are people like their partners harness
is a licensed software engineer in
Canada he actually has a license to
practice software engineering in this
country we have people who have written
one program language one programmer two
or three programs and they think their
software engineers work so the problem
is you got to teach all over here let me
get you guys aren't like you don't need
to sign a agreement here before just
talking them like
I like what you say and I grew up in
similar kind of world and I had to do
biological stuff for intracranial robots
can't have a software error pacemakers
came out of software and reliable
software well Dave Partners is again the
poster child for that he has a pacemaker
and he got out of the hospital and every
time he would fall asleep
the pacemaker would kick in and wake him
up there was no hysteresis it was a
bang-bang control system so he goes to
the doctor and he says give me the
programmers manual for this device and
the doctor says there is no programmers
manual so is there a user's menu a
doctor's operational manual the guy
spends five minutes trying without thumb
through his desk and he finally finds
one buried in the bottom is desk he
never read it okay so if you think that
medical devices are immune to all of
this because they're more carefully
designed well I don't think of but think
about the therac-25 there at twenty was
at a hardware interlock that prevented
you from switching from very high
intensity radiation to low intensities
therapeutic radiation when they built
the 35 that 25 they forgot to put that
in that interlocking software because it
wasn't in the hardware and they killed a
whole bunch of people I totally agree
with you and like I work for Medtronic
sand I did not work for an emetic era
medic had the problem with the
pacemakers and gee he didn't have the
problem with the radiation but he
accompanied Michael it did yeah you said
on my wife my wife had a Medtronic
pacemaker defibrillator with the bad
wires so that was a hardware failure
whatever question how can we reward
documenting these problems and
overcoming the embarrassment of how did
I let that get through let me throw that
question back at you how many papers do
you know about the failures that were
made in developing a system the dead
ends the things that they didn't pursue
because they knew it was the wrong thing
to do or because they spent two years
researching it and suddenly it backfires
when they put it into the system make
the claim that it's an economic problem
many companies won't pay for good
software ok bad self that's right again
you need to be heard by the the answer
to that question is Peter and my friends
Knuth who whenever errors were found he
paid power of two pennies mm-hmm and I
unintentionally found a couple errors
he's just a longtime friend to me and
you know I got two checks out of that no
it's not a large amount of money but
it's the attitude and then he did a
superb paper titled the errors of tech
and I'm particularly pissed off at
people who really like tech or latex he
doesn't care for latex personally but
the problem with with tech is you know
it held back volumes of the hours of
computer programming which is a far more
important work in our field than
pretty-looking text which really kicks
me up and you know he understands that I
feel this way I felt this way in 1980
whatever it was my first met him but no
I mean you guys aspired it till the
trying to be as good as dawn but you
guys are just largely talking that
regard he actually comes forth yeah good
good comment you know let's apply that
to software
and security there are more 0de
flaws known in the community in the dark
web and then there are known
vulnerabilities the mitre nist
repository is now something like 130
thousand vulnerabilities most of which
have not been fixed YUM
there's a topic you haven't mentioned
and that's a pretty serious one too
for vulnerabilities and that's policy
governance mhm I went to a talk on the
wasp which records vulnerabilities top
10 for api's so here's a question for
the audience
where's the best place to find API keys
for services that you don't have
permission to use github exactly right
people just put them in github in open
projects yeah and that even with every
perfect software and perfect hardware if
you don't write your policies right
you're not gonna have any security this
is really as a very good comment okay
you guys have been quiet any any
comments here okay so the the
frustrating part of all is is is it what
comes around goes around and it comes
back in and bites you another time and
we've talked about medical devices the
were there were not only pacemaker
problems and that there at 25 there are
lots of other documented medical devices
that are failing and even in the in the
last few months at risks I have more of
them say again that's really recently I
think this is like bridge building Hank
Henry Petroski who's an old friend of
mine writes the
an American scientist every every issue
he wrote a book on to error is human and
he book a whole bunch of books about
bridge building and he pointed out that
bridge builders got more and more
creative until they had a collapse then
they backed off and they bled to be much
more careful the Northwest vibration
yeah where where they never anticipated
that much shilly-shallying and
vertically horizontally motion the
London Walker bridge their walking
bridge again they built the damn thing
people walked on it and all of a sudden
it's unstable Petroski kept saying well
you know we learn a lot from the bridges
that fail because then we have to back
off and figure out what we did wrong the
9/11 building was an example of the way
that was engineered was was very badly
thought out okay good I'll have to get
back from my rehearsal at 7:30 and get
back to it my wife just recorded so
where do we stand in this whole mess
well the education is not up to snuff
the engineering standards are not up to
snuff the training of programmers is
always narrow the metrics are not right
absolutely that gets me into what do you
know about security metrics is this
system hundred percent secure no is it
one percent secure no
as soon as the Flies found it's 0%
secure okay is right
I personally assume that the attacker is
smarter than me
yeah and the attack will succeed so I
try to design software that will
minimize the damage that gets done when
the attack seems it's not if yeah and so
it is secure I can bound the damage yeah
and decide if that's tolerable so I'm
not putting a number on it like 1% or 2%
yeah good okay in doesn't mean anything
obviously life or other was a into
mechanical engineering breakage safety
working for a government lab I don't
tell me which one but he had to deal
evolving there's among other things
there is something called the failsafe
you can design stuff and you can
continuously test like your bridges are
your cables
yeah and they even have devices to do
that so yes yes but I don't see that
with computers that's right well it can
equal engineers are usually thought of
lower IQ no no they have to hide
Steve Steve literally used to call
himself as a civil engineer until
engineer yeah
I keep thinking that if we design given
something will fail that it's a fail
soft you know like the Northeast power
failure in 65 it didn't have to
propagate you know they had the
appropriate boundary conditions been set
to minimize yeah as I said that's a
problem that they thought they had
solved in 65 after the Northeast power
blackout and each successive fix was
subverted by a different mode of failure
one of the West Coast ones in fact the
one that took out all the West Coast
states and and Baja California was the
one where the guy who was the spotter in
the woods saw the fire breaking out he
couldn't find the phone number that he
was supposed to go okay so again we get
to the problem that is not just the
software it's not just the hardware it's
not just the squirrels and everything
else it's the whole system and that's
the thing that I think is most missing
from education today I can't think of a
single University that teaches systems
as systems where it's not just a system
on a chip it's the entire system of
everything that has to work either tell
me what that's very hard to do
faith safe for faith soft but there's
also over design turns out the people
who know the theory they now fight over
design yeah like for nuclear power
plants they used the best deal they
could
whatever yeah it turns out the besties
list gets brittle when when the nukes
come but yes anyway yeah yeah that's
right so again it's a holistic problem
the point is we don't see that I agree
and remember you are you are the beta
testers so we have known about principle
of least privilege since 74 yep when we
presented our virus safe computing
environment for Windows XP to Microsoft
yeah we pointed out that it wasn't
enforcing lease privilege and they said
of course it does at the level of the
user and it occurred to me that we never
talked about the granularity at which
we're applying lease privilege yeah and
that we should be applying it at the
smallest possible granularity and I just
haven't seen that discussed yeah you
will you will see that in what I'm
talking about in three weeks of course
and you're going to see granularity of
compartmentalization as well where you
can have gross compartmentalization you
can have very fine grain that is
efficiently executable by the hardware
it is not common at all and again that
is wonderful well that goes back to that
goes back this officer and Schroeder and
and the principle of least privilege
very quickly the cost issue if you have
multi level systems you may have to
spread it but ever Windows computers
don't run as do not run normally as an
administrator
you're an administrator if you know how
many people in this room were running
Windows one two three four Hornet
mission-critical stuff for about ten
years but before that every Intel
processor that was sold had a disclaimer
around this box that said not to be used
for medical Windows has the same
disclaimer same thing with Microsoft
yeah you had to go through a hospital
what do I see lots of Intel them I guess
and then there was the avi Reuben story
he's sitting in the hospital in
Morristown Memorial New Jersey and he
has total access to the hospital system
with his laptop there's no protection
whatsoever that was 10-15 years old I
want to I want to answer
Andy's could respond to Andy's remark
your remark was exactly my point about
the granularity of least privilege or
commonly used operating systems apply it
at the granularity of the user every
program you run has all your permissions
whether your administrator or not what
we did was we simply launched each
application in a different guest account
and then if cryptolocker ran it didn't
have access to any of the stuff
[Music]
okay yeah that should that shrink lab
thing is very annoying because all of
these life critical systems are using
systems that they've been told not to do
that
so that's that's not encouraging yeah so
many years ago when I was a deck there
was a memo passed around called bugs are
good have you seen the copy of this how
you think I had it yeah but the context
was hardware rather than software yeah
but the key part of it was to learn from
the bugs and and you know while you're
having lunch yeah about them
and see if you can take advantage of
right or not get caught about it yeah so
any software people do that a little bit
yes we certainly do it in the
architecture the Cambridge and Azariah
are developing there's a tremendous
amount of synergy there among the entire
team I've got about 20 people in
Cambridge working on this and they are
really really good talking to each other
so what Yelp does I this was a talk I
went to a couple years ago what Yelp
does is they assign a security inclined
person and they have a way of filtering
for these every development team has at
least one security inclined person who
makes sure that they have those
discussions over lunch at the basketball
court or during production meet during
product meetings this is great if that
person has social skills and is able to
communicate with everybody otherwise you
get into the you get into the horrible
effect that
well the Conway's law says that that's
going to kill you if these two guys
don't talk to each other the system is
going to reflect exactly that that
person was also a developer so it wasn't
that it was just somebody standing on
the side saying do security this person
was also one of the developers so part
of the team that's what they found made
the difference
it wasn't an outsider back to your
fundamental question how do you teach
this or what was how do you get people
to teach that properly well both both
Harvard and MIT are currently completely
renovating their computer science
curricula MIT I'll be back there in two
weeks and I long to chat with Howie
strobe involved in this and they are
really trying to make it hands-on where
everybody has detailed hands-on stuff
going on Harvard is doing the same thing
yeah
largely an economic issue if you could
get rich quickly producing reliable
software yeah all the students would be
signing up for reliabilities Rises
that's right it's not it's not in the
job description of most people and it's
not in the business plan of most
companies so Marc Stiegler got very
worried about One Laptop Per child that
all these people in the third world
countries would become vulnerable to
Nigerian letter attacks and so his
solution was to as part of the training
to use your laptop you had a mount of
Nigerian letter attack I wonder if the
education couldn't be a course on system
hacking to get people to think that way
yeah we're running out of time there so
the final comments last thoughts you
want to tell me who's doing it right
no okay well your your height your
people around some of us are trying to
do it right but I mean it the question
is how do you get this out to the
community at large
okay that's it for me for today thank
you very much for being here